if you're like me you're like okay
i'm working with this area but it's
still i don't know it's still
not like this l shape it hasn't yet been
broken down into something that i can
work with
okay these quadrants like if you can
think of a shape
that's close to one of these quadrants
what do you think it's closest
to correct what do you think triangles
oh okay so as a whole right i think this
does kind of look like a parallelogram
you can
sort of see the parallel sides each
individual quadrant
is a triangle right or it's close to a
triangle can you see
i could put like a shape like this
that looks pretty close to my quadrant
doesn't it it's not exactly
it's kind of off a little bit but it's
on the right track okay
so now i'm going to try and do this but
i'm going to try and do it better
we're going to do circle here okay
instead of
just taking the halves and halving them
i'm going to take the heart and i'm
going to divide them into more
smaller sections like this
okay so now i've got a pizza
okay i've got eight slices okay and when
i reassemble i'm going to skip this step
but i would like you to draw it
you can see i'm getting something
that's starting to look a little
different
right it's do you agree it's still the
same area right
still the same area still the same size
but i've rearranged it a bit haven't i
let's have a look
closely at this
okay so you see what's happening right
um earlier on adam mentioned
the whole shape the the whole shape that
i've got here
it kinda looks a bit like a
parallelogram
do you see that right look i've got two
sides here that really are parallel
you'll get
a rule or a couple sound check and then
this guy here
it's almost like a straight line isn't
it it's like a bumpy straight line
okay so can you imagine
i had four sectors first
then i had eight what do you think i've
gotta do next i'm gonna go again
i'm gonna take this guy right and i'm
going to divide it up
um this is about as practically far as
we can go in here
uh divide divide divide
divide okay this is starting to get
messy here we go one
two three
four there you go okay that's a lot of
sections
okay that's a lot of sections what's it
starting
to look like all right
here's what i've got here's what i've
got okay now
i've run out we take here it is okay
what we're doing here
is um we are approaching a particular
kind of shape
right it's getting more and more like
a shape that we actually know the area
of
okay oops that's a bit too high let's
move it
this is not only approaching a
parallelogram right
it's getting really close isn't it but
can you see
like see this edge of the parallelogram
each time i go along okay can you see
the edge is actually
changing suddenly like see this one's
like way off at an angle it's really
leaning over
right and then this one is leaning over
but only a little bit
and then this one is getting closer and
closer to
standing up straight yeah and what we're
going to say
yeah good you can see if i went so wait
let's do one more we will you already
drew three circles let's do a fourth one
here we go now if we were
if it were possible to divide up this
circle into
an infinite number of pieces right
uh what have i left out there you go so
how could you
because eventually there'd be no more
space okay well
like you can see it's like i've got i'm
getting i'm getting pieces that are kind
of chunky
to less chunky to now they're getting
thin and they'll get thinner
and thinner and thinner they'll get very
very thin but they'll never be
nothing like i've still got an actual
circle right
but what happens when i rearrange the
shape well what's it going to look like
it's going to look something like this
yeah right isn't it going to look like
this where
i have all these really really thin
slices right it's like trying to share a
pizza
with like a thousand people and it's
like okay you all get this tiny little
sliver
okay if you put all the slivers end to
end
you would get this rectangle
wouldn't it yes have the slightest bit
of a curve okay
so here's this amazing thing right if
we actually had like if we kept doing
this with actual paper
yes yes there would always be like this
bumpy bumpy
bumpy it'll just be a little bit bumpy
but you can see even my
my lines are bumpy right but as
mathematicians
we can do more than just imagine like a
real an actual piece of paper
we can take that circle into our minds
and we can do it so there's
really not just a lot of slices
we can imagine an infinite number of
slices
that are all infinitesimally thin you
can't do that in real life
but you can do it in your mind
mathematically we can do it
okay so here comes the most powerful
step
here we go okay um
i need another color here we go you told
me right the start of this lesson right
that the circumference of a circle is
two pi
r do you agree with that two pi r okay
so come over to my orange and black
circle here if the whole circumference
is two pi r
what is this distance here
just that distance there it's gonna be
yeah i think i heard it it's gonna be pi
r right
it's it's not it's not two pi r it's
half of that
because i've got half the circle it's pi
r
in the same way what about this part of
the black circle
it's also going to be pi r right so when
i come down here
can you see that this curved part that
long curved arc
over here became this guy
can you see that that curve became
this curve right it's still the same
length
isn't it like it's it's the same shape
literally just cut into pieces right
all right come up here right this green
one is exactly the same as the orange
one
it is also pi r
okay where's that green pie r where is
it here
yeah green very good it's here what
there we go there's pie r
okay i don't need to keep going up here
do i
what's it going to be down here i've got
this guy
pi r starts off really really wiggly
a bit less wiggly not very wiggly at all
once i get to this
special case because it's infinite
it's a straight line and it's still
pi up higher okay
now we're trying to work out an area
right it's a rectangle
what else will we need to work out the
area of this rectangle
yeah brendan we need a length right
we've got a width a breadth
and we want this thing we want this
thing now i wonder if you can help me
work out what it is
have a look at our shapes
yeah daniel what do you think i was
going to say
it's going to be the radius now how can
we see that
have a look at how we cut it it's um
it's this straight edge isn't it
and this straight edge and this straight
edge and they're all coming from the
center of the circle
right out to the circumference
and they're all the radius okay so
therefore
radius okay i'm almost there
i want an area right what's the area of
a rectangle again
it's length times breadth
r times pi r pi
r which is the same as the circumference
almost
almost it's so very close isn't it
there's still a pi
there's still an r but the two is at the
front here
and the twos up here okay now there's a
really easy way to remember which ones
which because they look so similar don't
they they look very similar
okay that's an area that's a length
when you're doing a length right it's
like something like centimeters or
meters or kilometers right
when you do an area what units do you
use
you might use centimeters square or
meters
squared or if it's a really big circle
kilometers squared
all areas are in square units
so that's why the area of a circle has
the square
in it right whereas the circumference
does not still has a two but it's in a
completely different spot
all right